dach zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live euren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
ja und die bundestagswahl ist gelaufen
die vorläufigen ergebnisse stehen fest
aber es steht auch fest das ist alles
nicht so einfach wird mit der
regierungsbildung und so stellt sich die
frage ja was machen wir jetzt einmal auf
geheim was los eine wichtige rolle kommt
den kleinen parteien zu der fdp und den
grünen
die könnten jetzt miteinander
entscheiden wer unter ihnen kanzlerin
oder gar kanzler wird aber das problem
ist die gehören erst nicht so wirklich
zum natürlichen habitat der jeweils
anderen partei da gibt es doch einige
hackl punkte wo sind also die
schnittmengen niveau könnte es haarig
werden oder wo könnte es vielleicht auch
funktionieren das wollen wir heute
besprechen und zwar mit der grünen
kandidatin oder damit der
grünen-bundestagsabgeordneten jamila
schäfer die ist das erste mal im
bundestag ist die erste direktkandidatin
die in bayern ein direktmandat gewonnen
hat außerdem mitglied jensen die ist
bundestagsabgeordnete für die fdp jetzt
zum zweiten mal in den bundestag gewählt
worden der spd politik berater erik
lücke wird uns später verraten die sich
die parteien da jetzt aufstellen müssen
aber bevor wir da starten reden wir erst
mal mit meiner kollegin nicole diekmann
im hauptstadtstudio in berlin über alles
was den letzten stunden passiert ist und
das wahlergebnis hallo nicole
wir schauen uns jetzt erstmal damit wir
auch die faktenlage haben gemeinsam das
vorläufige endergebnis der
bundestagswahl 20 21 an
laut vorläufigen amtlichen endergebnis
wird die spd bei der bundestagswahl
stärkste kraft mit 25,7 prozent die
union stürzt auf ein rekordtief
24,1 prozent auf platz drei die grünen
mit 14,8 eine verbesserung um 5,7
prozentpunkte dahinter die fdp mit 11,5
prozent leichte zugewinne die afg fällt
mit 10,3 prozent auf den fünften platz
zurück die linke stürzt auf 4,9 ab
bleibt aber trotzdem im bundestag durch
drei direktmandate für die
sitzverteilung des deutschen bundestags
ergeben sich daraus zwei 106 sitze für
die spd die union kommt auf 196 die
grünen auf 118 fdp 92 afd 83 die linke
hat noch 39 und der südschleswigsche
wählerverband zieht mit einem sitz
wieder in den bundestag ein für die
absolute mehrheit werden 368 der
insgesamt 735 sitze benötigt die frage
nach der kanzlerschaft bleibt weiter
offen sowohl spd als auch union
beanspruchen den auftrag zur
regierungsbildung für sich rechnerisch
wäre eine große koalition aus schwarz
und rot weiterhin möglich auch die ampel
aus spd grünen und fdp hätte eine
mehrheit ebenso das so genannte jamaika
bündnis aus union grünen und fdp
also alles offen nicole die große frage
ist jetzt was ist da eigentlich anders
als bei anderen wahlen es gibt ja
durchaus menschen die das erste mal
dabei sind und sich fragen ja okay ist
halt ein wahlergebnis wo ist das problem
ja es gibt mehrere neuigkeiten bzw
phänomene die zum ersten mal auftreten
bei dieser bundestagswahl nehmen wir
einmal diesen hauchdünnen abstand so sei
das eben in unserer grafik heraus
zwischen spd auf platz 1 und union auf
platz zwei das ist das erste das zweite
ist dass rein rechnerisch über die groko
kann man gleich noch mal reden
eigentlich nur noch dreier
konstellationen möglich sind und schauen
wir noch mal auf union und spd auf cdu
und spd die ehemals großen volksparteien
die sind geschrumpft die reden hier von
werten von um die 25 prozent also die
zeit der volksparteien scheint vorbei
was ist denn in der volkspartei also
gibt es da so eine definition und dass
man sagt okay bei so und so viel stimmen
oder personen zu lange mitglied anzahl
sind wir jetzt volkspartei oder ist das
jetzt auch so eine gefühlte definition
sag ich mal naja es gibt ja
unterschiedliche definitionen die wir
hatten auch immer dann unterschiedlich
benutzt wie sie gerade so in die
argumentation passen aber grob gesagt
ist nur volkspartei eine partei die
möglichst eine breite der bevölkerung
abdeckt thematisch das heißt keine
nischen politik macht keine
klientelpolitik sondern tatsächlich
versucht die breite masse der
bevölkerung vor allem der bevölkerung
die währung geht mit ihren themen und
ihren vorschlägen ihren lösungsansätzen
anzusprechen und das spiegelt sich
normalerweise schlägt sich ja
normalerweise dann auch eben nieder in
den wahlergebnissen wie gesagt bisher
hatten wir sagen wir mal zweier
konstellationen im bund wenn wir cdu und
csu die beiden schwestern als eine
partei zählen und das scheint jetzt
vorbei ich habe es ja eben schon gesagt
ich spreche das thema buch jetzt einmal
an das will keiner mehr vor vier jahren
musste die spd vom bundespräsidenten
frank walter steinmeier dazu regelrecht
getragen werden doch noch in die groko
zu gehen nach dem fdp chef christian
lindner die jamaika koalitionsgespräche
hatte platzen lassen das heißt vor vier
jahren war das interesse schon relativ
gering ausgeprägt noch mal in eine
gruppe zu gehen jetzt ist es glaube ich
noch weniger groß und auch in der
bevölkerung ist man einer gruppe
eigentlich müde eine große koalition
steht nicht für einen neuerungen steht
nicht für innovationen also amila stadt
hat heute in seiner pressekonferenz
gesagt er schießt im moment überhaupt
nichts aus hat das aber eher allgemein
begründet nämlich damit dass man als
demokratische partei gar nichts
ausschließen sollte nie ausschließen
sollte anderen demokratischen parteien
zu reden fügte aber hinzu das sei nun
wirklich nicht die gespräche die gerade
auf der tagesordnung stünden oder ganz
oben auf seiner agenda gut dann gucken
wir uns mal die möglichen koalitionen
noch mal an ich habe mir die grafik grad
noch mal hier auf den rechner gelegt
damit wir das alles zusammen uns noch
mal kurz anschauen können weil es gibt
ja einige möglichkeiten guck mal hier
kommt als erstes die kenia koalition aus
spd cdu und grüne kurze frage nicole er
nicht oder
eher nicht eher unwahrscheinlich er
deshalb unwahrscheinlich weil dann eben
wieder spd und union im bunde
miteinander werden und das habe ich ja
gerade erläutert
da gibt es größere träume die man
verfolgt die mannheimer verfolgt als
denen das heißt auch die deutschland
koalition noch mal kurz auf meinen
rechner hier spd cdu und fdp ist im
grunde das gleiche nur in gelb auch das
wäre raus dann kommen wir jetzt zu den
nächsten spannenden möglichkeit quasi
auf platz drei der möglichen dann ja
absoluten sitze ist die ampel koalition
ampel wegen roth spd grün und gelb die
würden locker über die 368 sitze
verfügen für wie wahrscheinlich hättest
du das denn naja also nehmen wir mal die
spd die hat wenn auch hauchdünn die
mehrheit gestern geholt mit ihrem
kanzlerkandidaten und dieser
kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz hat zb in
den letzten vor allem im letzten teil
aber auch in dem der forschern und auch
in anderen formaten in denen er zusammen
mit der grünen kanzlerkandidaten
annalena baerbock saß sehr deutlich zu
erkennen gegeben dass die grünen sein
lieblings koalitionspartner wären und
auch annalena baerbock schien das zu
erwidern das heißt da gibt es eine große
schnittmenge zum beispiel was soziale
themen angeht nun haben wir noch die fdp
mit im bunde fdp und grüne liegen vor
allem die beiden aber auch spd und fdp
liegen in vielen fragen auseinander das
heißt da ist die schnittmenge nicht zu
groß nicht allzu groß aber das bemühen
ist da miteinander zu reden gestern der
so genannten elefantenrunde in der
berliner runde von ard und zdf hat fdp
chef christian lindner ja schon annalena
baerbock von den grünen die hand
gereicht gesagt wir reden jetzt erst mal
miteinander denn so wie es aussieht sind
die fdp und die grünen königsmacher
die grünen liegen etwas weiter vorne mit
dem wahlergebnis aber die fdp muss mit
ins boot und ich habe es ja eben schon
gesagt vor vier jahren hat christian
lindner die jamaika
gespräche platzen lassen für viele auch
in der union auch bei den grünen sehr
sehr überraschend und auch für viele
leute aus seiner partei das hat man eben
lange übel genommen das ist eben die
letzten vier jahre hat es ihm immer
nachgegangen das heißt lindner muss
nicht alles mitmachen die fdp muss nicht
alles mitmachen aber
es wäre sehr schwierig noch mal vier
jahre später zusagen machen wir nicht
das heißt also jamaika wäre auch noch
eine mögliche option ist auch hier auf
dem rechner eine schwarz grün gelb kommt
auch über die 368 sitze also auch
möglich das hältst du auch für denkbar
naja also erstmal muss man ja sagen nach
diesem wahlkampf ist ja so ungefähr
alles denkbar es überrascht würde einen
ja kaum noch etwas überraschen und wie
ich gerade gesagt habe lindner muss
nicht alles mitmachen die fdp muss nicht
bei allem mitmachen ist aber sehr
interessiert daran mit den eine
regierung zu gehen und auf den ersten
blick könnte man sagen naja
schwarz-grünen gerade jetzt beim klima
thema die liegen nicht so weit
auseinander die grünen und die cdu vor
allen dingen aber es gibt eine
grünen-basis die ist er der spd
zugeneigt die fdp sah in beiden modellen
mit im bunde das heißt entweder gehen
die grünen mit fdp und union in einer
koalition oder mit fdp und spd beim
klima thema wie gesagt liegt man gar
nicht weit entfernt von der union vor
ein von der cdu
wer tatsächlich als an der spd das ist
aber nicht die einzige frage es ist
überhaupt nicht ausgeschlossen dass man
miteinander koaliert aber im moment
wahrscheinlicher ist die koalition mit
spd und der fdp auch das ist ja auch
wichtig es läuft ja schon die debatte
jahr rein rechnerisch hat armin laschet
als zweiter mit seiner partei nach
dieser wahl auch die möglichkeit eine
koalition zu bilden aber hat er die
moralische berechtigung eine koalition
zu bilden wenn er als kanzlerkandidat
mit seiner partei nicht die meisten
stimmen geholt hat und ganz klar dass
das wäre es so liest sich heute die
bewertung dessen was gerade stattfindet
also wird es kommentiert mit der frage
hat er die moralische berechtigung
tatsächlich als zweitplatzierter an der
spd vorbei eine koalition zu bilden die
frage stellt sich natürlich anders wenn
die spd aus welchen gründen auch immer
mit den anderen beiden nicht ins
geschäft kommt aber viele kommentatoren
schreiben heute jetzt ist erstmal die
spd am zuge und das ist kostendiskussion
für für richard david precht wirklich
sorgen dass nicht das aber noch anfügen
darf jahren bin ich auch fertig mit
diesem sehr man das ist auch eine frage
die die grüne spitze dann auch ihrer
basis verkaufen muss in dem fall wenn
sie sagen sollte wir gehen mit der union
in einer koalition auch da werden dann
von der grünen-basis sicherlich fragen
auftauchen nach dem motto warum denn mit
denen die anderen haben doch gewonnen
das fragen wir auch gleich mal wir reden
ja noch mit einer grünen abgeordneten
und einer fdp-abgeordneten hier kommt
noch eine frage auf die es ganz spannend
von einem user oder einer userin das
passt auch vom user namen ganz dünnes 1
wie wäre es mit einer
minderheitsregierung tatsächlich sind
hier mehrere kommentatoren oder
kommentatorinnen die danach fragen also
rot grüne minderheitsregierung wäre
denkbar gibt es auch in anderen
europäischen ländern
realistisch nicht realistisch das mag
man in deutschland einfach nicht und
ehrlich gesagt also so zwingend stellt
sich diese koalition ja nicht man hat ja
noch nicht mal wirklich angefangen
miteinander zu sondieren also jetzt
gleich zu sagen wir gehen in eine
minderheitenregierung warum so jetzt
haben sich heute alle geäußert alle
spitzenkandidaten der parteien wir hören
mal zuerst rein bei olaf scholz von der
spd ich möchte eine regierung bilden die
auf vertrauen beruht der parteien
untereinander das muss ja darum gehen
dass man nicht nur die aufgaben
bewältigt über die man sich in einem
koalitionsvertrag verständigt sondern
auch die vielen aufgaben die auf einen
zukommen die man am anfang gar nicht
erkennen kann auch die letzten jahre der
regierung waren immer davon geprägt dass
wir neue dinge zu bewältigen hatten die
sich nicht abgezeichnet hatten während
der koalitionsbildung insofern geht es
schon darum dass das gut läuft ich finde
es gibt auch einen grundsatz der ganz
wichtiges regierungsparteien müssen
einander vertrauen sie müssen
miteinander zusammenarbeiten wollen und
nicht gewissermaßen immer hinten herum
erzählen was die anderen alles schlecht
machen die schwarz-gelbe koalition ist
sicherlich in den letzten jahren das
abschreckende beispiel für
regierungstätigkeit gewesen weil das
vertrauen zwischen cdu csu und fdp
überhaupt nicht existiert hat ich glaube
daran erinnern sich auch viele in der
fdp noch sehr genau wie schlecht das
auch für sie von seiten der cdu csu
damals gelaufen ist und deshalb sollte
es hier ganz anders sein ich finde eine
regierung die sich gebildet hat muss
auch so miteinander regieren dass sie
sich zutraut auch wiedergewählt zu
werden
so das waren jetzt viele worte von olaf
scholz er hat ein bisschen die
eigenschaft finde ich dass er hinterher
man nicht mehr so richtig weiß was er
eigentlich gesagt hat kannst du das noch
mal für uns übersetzen im grunde hat er
der union gesagt überlegt euch mal wie
mit euch umgegangen worden ist wie euer
verhältnis war zudem
überzeuge er hat zu entschuldigen er hat
der fdp gesagt überlegt euch doch mal
wie die union mit euch umgegangen ist
wie es euch ergangen ist als die
gemeinsam in einer koalition watt also
im grunde sagt er nehmt mich wie kommst
du uns dieses kuscheliger armin laschet
hat sich auch geäußert gehören auch mal
rein wir brauchen auch das wichtige
anliegen dass wir zu wirtschaftlichem
wachstum wieder zurückkommen
das ist ein besonderes anliegen der fdp
das wir teilen wenn den grünen teilen
wir das engagement für den klimaschutz
und die umwandlung unseres industrieland
zu einem klimaneutralen
industrieland zum weiteren vorgehen wir
sind im gespräch wir werden die
gespräche sicher auch noch formalisiert
in den nächsten tagen fortsetzen aber
hier ist mir wichtig das darf nicht das
klein klein sein dass wir aus früheren
sondierungen kennen
vier wochen lang sondieren mit
verhandlungen über jeden kleinen komma
strich
mit vielen eckigen klammern was alles
nicht gelöst ist und am ende dann eine
gescheiterte sondierung kann ich das
verfahren dieses mal sein wir brauchen
gespräche aus denen deutlich werden muss
trauen sich die jeweiligen partner das
zu das gemeinsam zu machen ja oder nein
ja das ganze klang jetzt aber nicht nach
niederlage und ich gehen die opposition
sondern so ein bisschen nach ich will
mitreden oder erhöht das klang vor allem
nach guck mal grüne guckt mal fdp mit
uns würde es prima funktionieren und er
hat ja gerade gesagt die gespräche in
den nächsten tagen das ist was anderes
als zu sagen dir überlassen jetzt dem
wald seeger der spd das zepter die sind
jetzt an der reihe sollte da alles
schief gehen sollten die drei nicht
zurande kommen miteinander
dann stehen wir für gespräche bereit
nein armin laschet sagte gerade er würde
parallel auch gespräche führen dann sind
wir gespannt was die nächsten tage dabei
rauskommt bis hierhin erstmal vielen
dank nicole für deine ausführungen und
für seine analyse so auch die größte
frage könnte also sein wie werden sich
grüne und fdp verhalten zueinander
können die sich irgendwie einigen so
dass es dann einen größeren dritten
partner dazu gibt oder funktioniert das
nicht die vorsitzenden der beiden
parteien haben sich heute auch vor die
presse gestellt und wir haben mal zwei
ausschnitte daraus
zwischen grüne und fdp gibt es die
größten inhaltlichen
unterschiede bei den parteien des
demokratischen zentrums die jetzt über
eine regierungsbildung miteinander
sprechen könnten deshalb macht es sinn
angesichts dieser bisweilen bestehenden
polarisierung den gemeinsamen grund zu
suchen
zugleich sind grüne und fdp aber auch
die parteien die sich am stärksten gegen
den status quo der großen koalition
gewarnt haben weder die union noch die
spd stehen für aufbruch wir haben einen
klaren auftrag von den wählerinnen und
wählern bekommen für einen aufbruch in
unserem land zu sorgen auch wenn das
ergebnis deutlich hinter dem zurück
liegt was wir erwartet und für was wir
gekämpft haben jetzt eine erneuerung
dieses landes kann zu gehen und deutlich
zu machen dass wir nicht nur
schrittweise voran kommen müssen sondern
dass wir wirklich eine erneuerung
brauchen in der infrastruktur in der
digitalisierung unseres landes und dass
die klimapolitik querschnitts politik
einer nächsten bundesregierung sein muss
das bedeutet nicht nur im umweltressort
verankert sondern sich durch zieht durch
die wirtschafts- und industriepolitik
die verkehrspolitik die
landwirtschaftspolitik weil die frage
der klimaneutralität die zukunftsaufgabe
unserer gesellschaft und damit auch die
zukunft für den wohlstand in unserem
land ist
so und christian lindner fdp chef hat
heute angekündigt ist wird vor
sondierungsgespräche mit den grünen
geben wir können jetzt hier quasi schon
das vor vor sondierungsgespräch führen
und zwar mit guido jansen wiedergewählte
bundestagsabgeordnete für die für die
fdp und mit janina schäfer die ist für
bündnis 90 die grünen in den bundestag
gewählt worden als erste bayerische
direktkandidatin der grünen ihnen beiden
gratulation herzlich willkommen
hallo genannt vielen dank so dann fangen
wir mal an bei frau schäfer als ihm klar
wurde dass sich ihre partei mit der fdp
einigen muss was haben sie da gedacht
naja ich habe mir gesagt das wird eine
große herausforderung denn natürlich
haben wir zum beispiel bei der frage wie
wir den klimaschutz angehen doch größere
differenzen die fdp will dass er mit dem
emissionshandel lösen und das dauert
sehr lange die habe war keine zeit
werden deswegen haben wir als grüne
natürlich vor allem den früheren
kohleausstieg zum beispiel vorgeschlagen
und auch noch eine reihe weiterer
maßnahmen zum beispiel bei der
verkehrswende weiterzukommen und
trotzdem ist natürlich auch einiges
möglich was die modernisierung des
landes angeht und deshalb müssen wir
jetzt natürlich offen gespräche führen
und natürlich als grüne haben wir dabei
das ziel dass wir so viel wie möglich
beim thema klimaschutz rausbekommen und
natürlich auch bei der frage sozialer
zusammenhalt
dass wir zukunftsinvestitionen in die
hand nehmen ich glaube da muss sich die
fdp dann auch noch ein bisschen bewegen
damit wir wirklich auch das land
modernisieren können tja frau jansen
modernisierung ist aber eigentlich ja
das stichwort für die fdp damit haben
sie im wald hans geworben was war denn
ihr erster gedanke als sie die zahlen
sagen und dachten okay ich muss mich mit
den grünen wahrscheinlich irgendwie
einigen
positiv um ehrlich zu sein ich komme aus
schleswig-holstein wir haben da eine
erfolgreiche regierende seit vier jahren
erfolgreich regieren jamaika-regierung
also wir kennen uns durchaus auch mit
den grünen es gibt in anderen
landesverbänden oder in anderen ländern
auch grün fdp-beteiligung in der
regierung von daher glaube ich ist der
ansatz über das einende und über die
gemeinsamkeiten zuerst zu sprechen und
dann an die herausforderungen die es
sicherlich gibt die gibt es auch mit
anderen parteien mit denen man dann
sprechen würde zu sprechen und ich
glaube das ist der ansatz den wir damals
in schleswig holstein gewählt haben der
funktioniert bis dato ganz gut und
deswegen
habe ich jetzt erst mal keine negativen
gedanken weil das wie sich dann ein
programmatisches
bild in den nächsten wochen und
vielleicht monate zeichnen wird dann
stück für stück angegangen wird gut dann
wählen wir jetzt hier den klassischen
journalistischen anderen und gucken uns
erst mal an passte ihm vielleicht nicht
so richtig funktionieren könnte wo die
knackpunkte sind zum beispiel wir haben
es gerade schon gehört thema klimaschutz
wir haben mal die unterschiedlichen
positionen ihrer beiden parteien
zusammen gefasst
die fdp möchte deutschland bis 2050
klimaneutral machen cdu csu und spd bis
2045 so steht es auch im aktuellen
klimaschutzgesetz die grünen peilen
spätestens 2041 an
auch bei den energiequellen differenzen
beispiel der bereits beschlossene
kohleausstieg die fdp weist darauf hin
dass der ausstieg mit enormen
herausforderungen verbunden sei spd und
union bekennen sich zum vereinbarten
ausstieg die grünen wollen ihn schon bis
solaranlagen auf allen geeigneten
dächern fordern die grünen und die spd
die union möchte die technologie
ebenfalls fördern die fdp verweist auf
die bedeutung solcher anlagen
die grünen wollen ab 2030 keine neuwagen
mit verbrennungsmotor mehr zulassen spd
und cdu/csu erwähnen kein konkretes
datum
die fdp lehnt so einen zulassungsstopp
ab
gut wir fangen wir an beim polo ausstieg
frau jensen werden sie denn bereit den
kohleausstieg nach vorne zu ziehen um
den grünen entgegen zu kommen
ich glaube das sind genau die fragen die
die verhandlungsteams klären müssen
hinter geschlossenen türen damit es
erfolgreiche verhandlungen sind geklärt
werden müssen und deswegen glaube ich
mache das überhaupt gar keinen sinn da
jetzt heute in diesem format darüber zu
sprechen ich denke was wichtig ist und
das ist dann das einen damit würde ich
starten zu sagen dass der klimawandel
eine herausforderung ist der sich die
besagten parteien die eine nächste
koalition schmieden müssen sehr bewusst
sind und auch sehr verantwortungsvoll
damit umgehen werden wir schlagen
mechanismen vor die vielleicht andere
parteien ablehnen aber ich glaube da wir
werden einen kompromiss finden der in
die richtige richtung geht nämlich bis
2050 oder eben auch früher wenn man das
entsprechend miteinander vereinbaren
kann und das geht auch bei dem
mechanismus mit dem emissionshandel den
wir vorschlagen entsprechend auf den weg
zu bringen und die nächsten wochen sind
das keine punkte die nicht auszuräumen
sie müssen doch ein gefühl haben dass
die fdp da irgendwie sich bewegen kann
wenn wenn sie jetzt immer sagen das
müssen wir den teams verhandeln dann
können wir das gespräch gleich sein
lassen
das aber das ist glaube ich genau das
was jetzt die politik und wir hier als
als neu gewählte abgeordnete oder
wiedergewählte abgeordnete schaffen
müssen einerseits nicht nur zu mauern
und andererseits aber zu erklären was
wir hier politisch gerade machen und
wenn wir in schleswig holstein und da
auf dieser basis versuche ich das jetzt
gerade zu erklären eine koalition
geschmiedet haben dann haben wir das
hinter verschlossenen türen gemacht weil
man sich mit den und das sind am ende
menschen die sich über den weg trauen
müssen und eine vertrauensbasis
schmieden müssen egal bei welcher
thematischen frage das können wir bei
klimawandel machen das können wir bei
menschenrechten bei außen- und
sicherheitspolitik machen oder eben bei
bildungs oder wirtschaftspolitik die
müssen hinter verschlossenen türen in
einem vertrauensvollen gespräch auf
einer basis miteinander erst mal zurecht
kommen bevor wir mit ihnen als
medienvertretern dann bestimmte
ergebnisse vor formulieren die absolut
noch nicht feststehen und das ist dann
am ende vielleicht eine bittere wahrheit
aber ich glaube die wird häufig dann
unter den tisch fallen gelassen und
deswegen werden sie von mir heute nur
diesbezüglich
diese diese botschaft mitbekommen so
leid es mir tut aber alles andere werden
die entsprechenden fachpolitikerin und
fachpolitiker vereinbaren wenn der
zeitpunkt gekommen ist dann frage ich
mal frau schäfer der frühere
kohleausstieg um jeden preis der ist ja
quasi ihr ziel ist dass so eine harte
grenze wo sie meinen okay also da werden
sich die grünen nicht bewegen weil das
ist notwendig die fdp das kann ich ihnen
ja schon mal sagen frau jensen ihr
vorgesetzter hat am freitag zum beispiel
solchen leitplanken gesetzt er hat
gesagt hier beisteuern so ein beispiel
darf man einen rang hinter weiche ich
nicht ab wie ist das mit dem
kohleausstieg frau schäfer glauben sie
dass die grünen sich da nicht bewegen
werden
also für uns ist natürlich erst einmal
total wichtig dass wir das land so
schnell wie möglich klimaneutral machen
und der kohleausstieg ist ehrlicherweise
die einfachste möglichkeit ganz
schnelles co2 budget unterzubringen
genau deshalb ist es für uns natürlich
eine wichtige forderung jetzt nicht im
symbolischen sinne wollen wir jetzt
einfach pragmatisch und ganz wichtiger
aspekt wäre um wirklich die klimaziele
noch einhalten zu können deswegen können
sie davon ausgehen dass es für uns ein
wichtiger punkt ist weil ja unser ziel
ist diese klima-ziele wirklich
einzuhalten auf die sich auch unsere
regierung
geeinigt hat und trotzdem muss ich mich
wieder jensen andächtige schon und
anschließend das wir natürlich jetzt
nicht in diesem format ganz konkrete
sondierungsgespräche führen werden das
gebührt auch den respekt vor dem
verhandlerin und verhandlern aber wie
auch die ganze schon gesagt hat
natürlich wird es notwendig sein dass
wir beim klimaschutz vorankommen und
eben auch die notwendigen maßnahmen für
das pariser klima abkommen erreichen
sonst macht natürlich eine grüne
regierungsbeteiligung auch wenig setzen
vorher sind was hat dann ihre partei
eigentlich gegen den geplanten oder den
frühzeitigen ausstieg aus dem
verbrennungsmotor wirklich zu sagen okay
wir setzen uns jetzt hier eine deadline
22 30 steigen wir aus die meisten
autohersteller haben doch ich schon
gesagt wir planen da rauszugehen
genau die meisten autohersteller die
meisten unternehmen zeigen ja heute
schon das ist marktwirtschaftliche
lösungen gibt die sie proaktiv auf den
markt bringen und dann anbieten aber ich
komme aus dem dörflichen oder ländlichen
raum und da sind viele menschen auch
finanziell gar nicht in der lage sich
auf einmal auf ein elektrofahrzeug wie
es wünschenswert wäre
umzustellen weil die finanzmittel dafür
gar nicht da sind und ich glaube dass
das politik auch so einfach nicht
vorgeben kann deswegen plädieren wir als
freie demokraten für
technologieoffenheit auch für die
möglichkeit unterschiedliche antriebs
antriebs und mobilitätsformen nutzen zu
können das sind ganz vielschichtige
fragen die man erklären muss von denen
den stoßzeiten des öffentlichen
personennahverkehrs aber bis eben auch
hin zu dem klassischen pkw den viele
familien eben brauchen und auf denen sie
ganz dringend angewiesen sind mich
eingeschlossen und deswegen glaube ich
dass politik der lösungen schmieden und
erarbeiten muss die auch tatsächlich
realität verträglich sind und ich glaube
dass so strikte grenzen und werte
grenzwerte oder strikte zahlen an die
man sich dann klammert nicht unbedingt
das sind was am ende die lösung bringt
ich glaube vielmehr dass wir politisch
dafür sorgen müssen auch internationale
partner davon zu überzeugen dass
klimaschutz notwendig ist damit wir hier
auf diesem erdball gemeinsam unter einer
atmosphäre die übrigens ja nicht nur die
deutsche ist sondern die europäische und
globale
gemeinsam leben können oder sie könnten
ja gegen siena
vorangehenden partner zu finden wie die
volksrepublik china oder auch brasilien
die an einen tisch zu bekommen und ich
glaube da sind wir uns in deutschland
doch da auch er ein ich gut man könnte
trotzdem ja sagen es ist setzen zeichen
so 20.30 haben wir auch damit dann kauft
man sich auf dessen verbrennungsmotor
auto das kann man noch mal zehn 15 jahre
fahren das ist ja jetzt nicht so etwas
knie gebrochen aber frau schäfer finden
sie die argumente von franz sind
überzeugend also dass sie hat ja doch
durchaus gesagt es gibt menschen die
haben schwierigkeiten mit
der jensen hat ja gerade auch schon
selber gesagt dass die autoindustrie da
schon weiter weiß die politik hören
sondern dass die politik der großen
koalition und der fdp an der stelle
und das stimmt mich auch zuversichtlich
dass wir das auch hinbekommen weil es
ist klar dass wir in der verkehrswende
endlich weiterkommen ist er seit 1990
die emissionen im verkehrsbereich nicht
reduziert und wir müssen für
ambitionierten klimaschutzes natürlich
in jedem sektor machen auch endlich in
der verkehrspolitik und vor allem müssen
auch dafür sorgen dass unsere automobile
stry
innovationsdruck bekommt für neue
antriebe ich glaube das ist auch schon
durch diese debatte des ausstiegs aus
dem verbrennungsmotor angestoßen worden
und ich glaube dass wir diese debatte
auch weiterführen müssen damit wir ja
auch als industrieland arbeiter bei den
technologien vorne mit dabei sind und
vielleicht ergeben sich da auch wieder
schnittpunkte mit der fdp denn
klimaschutz zu machen bedeutet ja auch
das land zu modernisieren
innovationstreiber zu sein in der welt
und beschließt sich ja auch eben nicht
damit aus sondern ist eben gerade auch
teil davon neue partnerinnen und partner
zu finden um diese technologien auch
weltweit voranzutreiben
und darüber werden wir sicherlich dann
auch in sondierungsgesprächen sprechen
müssen okay das klingt schon fast nach
willkommen auf einen gemeinsamen nenner
wir gehen wir zum nächsten punkte zum
mindestlohn alles was die finanzen
angeht ist zwischen grünen und fdp nicht
immer so zusammen zu bringen haben wir
festgestellt wir gucken uns mal die
position an eine sofortige anhebung des
mindestlohns auf zwölf euro pro stunde
fordern die grünen die liberalen wollen
beim mindestlohn keinen
überbietungswettbewerb wie sie es nennen
die lohnuntergrenze will die fdp aber
auch nicht wieder abschaffen die
sozialdemokraten sprechen sich für den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn von mindestens
12 euro aus die union ist gegen eine
politische erhöhung des mindestlohns
fordert aber bei minijobs eine anhebung
von 450 auf 550 euro im monat
so da frage ich meine frau schäfer an
was halten sie denn davon also
mindestlohn ok drauf aber dann auch
diese 450 euro grenze heben ist das
vorstellbar
also ich finde dass es politisch falsch
und
das wäre ja genau einen punkt der wieder
die prekarisierung des arbeitsmarktes
vorantreibt wir haben ja ein großes
problem mit dieser sogenannten minijob
falle die vor allem frauen in
altersarmut bringt und ein großes
armutsrisiko darstellt deswegen das
nicht eigentlich genau in die andere
richtung gehen und für mehr
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs
sorgen und das ist genau die andere
richtung deswegen stehen wir auch für
einen mindestlohn und eine verbesserung
der arbeitsbedingungen gerade auch für
frauen ein und gegen dieses alters
armutsrisiko also das wäre mit uns nicht
so einfach zu machen und ich glaube dass
es auch für uns grüne und der große
verantwortung ist die soziale schere
zwischen arm und reich wieder zu
schließen und auch dafür zu sorgen dass
die krisenkosten
nachweislich die ärmsten der armen
bezahlen sondern wir das solidarisch als
gesellschaft gemeinsam meistern ergänzen
warum meinen sie denn also wenn ich
jetzt der argumentation von frau schäfer
folge dass man den mindestlohn anheben
muss wenn sie wie gesagt gerade der
meinung ist dass dadurch das risiko der
altersarmut wieder steigt weil das eben
keiner sozialversicherungspflichtigen
jobs sind die neu entstehen
ich glaube jetzt in zwei miteinander
verzahnte aber nicht unbedingt komplett
aufeinander folgende fragen die man
klären muss wir stehen auch dafür dass
der die minijob grenze erhöht wird weil
das vor allen dingen ja auch jobs sind
die und das hat ja corona auch gezeigt
die studentinnen und studenten die junge
menschen ausüben um sich ein bisschen
was dazu zu verdienen diese grenze die
es in den letzten jahren fast
jahrzehnten ja nie wirklich angehoben
worden und das finden wir es eigentlich
dringend überfällig die andere frage ist
wie menschen gar nicht erst in
altersarmut kommen können beispielsweise
und da würde ich sagen kann man vor
einigen den den punkt infrage ja auch
nannte nämlich dass vor allem frauen ja
in den niedriglohnsektoren oder eben
auch mit minijobs eben nicht
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
sind und so häufig in altersarmut kommen
können dass wir an einem anderen punkt
ansetzen der aber elementar dafür ist
nämlich an der kinderbetreuung an
flexiblen arbeitszeitmodellen damit auch
die vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
und corona hat gezeigt dass vor allen
dingen frauen als erste wieder zurück
in die häusliche umgebung kam weil sie
sich auf die kindererziehung und das
homeschooling
fokussiert haben dass das genau dazu
führt dass frauen eben nicht in
hauptberuflicher beschäftigung oder in
vollzeit beschäftigung sondern eher ein
teilzeit oder oder eben in minijobs
bleiben und ich glaube wenn man an der
kita betreuung schraubt das sind
landesaufgaben sind kommunale aufgaben
da müssen wir entsprechend mit ländern
gemeinsam arbeiten dafür sorgen dass es
eben nicht linke tasche rechte tasche
ist einen kita-platz zu bezahlen den
mann dann gleichzeitig in einem
halbtagsjob eigentlich schon wieder quer
finanzieren muss ich glaube solche
fragen müssen wir angehen das sind die
großen leitlinien aber ich glaube auch
da da finden wir eher gemeinsamkeiten
als unterschiede in den gesprächen die
hoffentlich bald anstehen also ich höre
er so die frage ist nicht ob das ziel
das gemeinsame ist man wie man dahin
kommt da gibt es irgendwie
unterschiedliche ansätze wir sind
gespannt was da die teams besprechen wir
kommen zum letzten punkt steuern
lieblingsthema der fdp auch da
verschiedene ansätze wir gucken mal rein
vermögende stärker belasten und den
spitzensteuersatz anheben das möchten
die grünen die fdp hingegen will dass
der spitzensteuersatz erst ab einem
höheren einkommen als bisher greifen
außerdem fordert sie steuerentlastungen
für kleine und mittlere einkommen
die spd will spitzenverdiener stärker
belasten steuern für kleine und mittlere
einkommen aber gerechter gestalten die
union lehnt steuererhöhungen ab
jetzt haben sie hat gesagt sie wollen
erst mal konstruktiv anfangen jetzt habe
ich meinen konstruktiven vorschlag also
die grünen sagen ja sie wollen einen
höheren spitzensteuersatz
die fdp sagt sie möchte dass der
spitzensteuersatz später greift das
könnte man noch kombinieren indem man
jetzt einmal sagt okay der
spitzensteuersatz für einkommen bis
150000 euro bleibt bei 42 prozent und
darüber gibt es nochmal neuen
spitzensteuersatz von summe x10 ich
jetzt nicht näher benennen möchte dass
wir auch eine kombination die denkbar
wäre wäre das für sie möglich
also wir als fdp haben in unser programm
vorgeschlagen und deswegen sind wir auch
zumindest im vergleich der parteien der
mitte die die ja auch jetzt hier heute
in rede waren diejenigen die alle
einkommen also von klein bis groß
entlasten wollen und auch diejenigen die
vorschlagen am meisten zu entlassen wir
wollen den gesamten bereich der
belastung im grunde nach rechts
verschiedenen rechts der bereich wäre wo
höhere einkommen angesiedelt sind und so
schafft man nicht nur das eine ganz
bestimmte gruppe mehr belastet wird also
wenn zum beispiel
besserverdienende diejenigen sind die am
ende mehr belastet werden dann müssen
wir auch gucken wo sich das
möglicherweise in einem unternehmen was
auch arbeitsplätze schafft niederschlägt
das würde möglicherweise eher dazu
führen dass das weniger jobs geschaffen
werden dass weniger möglichkeiten
bestehen auch auf gutes gehalt
abzustellen und deswegen glaube ich hat
es dann nicht etwas mit konstruktivem
ablehnend zu tun wenn ich sage dass wir
da bei unserem vorschlag bleiben und
schauen was vielleicht auch von anderer
seite auf uns zu gebracht wird aber ich
glaube dass es wichtig ist nach einer
zeit wo doch die belastung sehr hoch
waren und auch weiterhin hoch bleiben
werden weil corona ja sicherlich auch
nachwehen nach sich ziehen wird da jetzt
nicht über belastungen sondern über
entlastungen zu reden weil dann ganz
viele menschen auch viel mehr
möglichkeiten dem portemonnaie er beim
auch vielleicht in in veränderungen im
lebensbereich nachdenken und das ist
glaube ich und aus unserer sicht der
richtige weg frau schäfer ihre parteien
möchte einen höheren spitzensteuersatz
einführen jetzt haben wir gerade gehört
die fdp möchte eigentlich alle entlasten
was meinen sie zu diesen gedanken
ja also ich glaube bei dem thema
steuerpolitik merkt man schon dass wir
sehr fundamental unterschiedliche
herangehensweise an das thema haben weil
der plan der fdp bedeutet ja einfach
dass sehr viele löcher in den
staatshaushalt gerissen werden dadurch
dass hohe einkommen besonders stark
entlastet werden denn von hohen
steuerentlastungen die sozusagen nicht
nur die mittleren und kleinen einkommen
betreffen profitieren natürlich die
reichsten der reichen am allermeisten
und unser ansatz ist eben genau das
nicht zu tun sondern gerade in einer
zeit wo wir die frauen sind ja auch
selber schon gesagt hat hohe belastungen
hatten dafür zu sorgen dass eben auch
genug geld da ist um investitionen zu
tätigen zb eine gerechte digitales
bildungssystem was wirklich
chancengerechtigkeit schafft da sind wir
uns vom ziel her wahrscheinlich sogar
einig aber vom weg her vielleicht nicht
auch die frage wie schaffen wir
eigentlich ein unternehmer
investitionsfreundliches umfeld für
unternehmen ich glaube auch da brauchen
wir investitionen auch von staatlicher
hand um unternehmen in klimaneutrale
investitionen zu bringen und auch dabei
zu unterstützen und gleichzeitig wir
haben es ja auch gerade schon
angesprochen mit denen
kinderbetreuungsmöglichkeiten auch die
müssen finanziert werden und wir haben
eben gesagt wir brauchen dafür
investitionen und eben auch eine
gerechtere steuerpolitik damit eben
nicht an der falschen stelle gekürzt
wird gerade jetzt in der korona pandemie
und ich glaube das ist tatsächlich
ehrlicherweise das thema wo wir am
schwersten zusammenkommen und wohl auch
viele gespräche notwendig sind damit wir
hier wirklich zu einer guten lösung am
ende kommen wenn wir mit der fdp
tatsächlich in eine regierung kommen
wollen die für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit sorgen seien es ja dann
liegt frau jensen zustimmend letzte
frage an sie beide mit der bitte um eine
kurze antwort weil pro jensen hatte noch
anschlusstermin ist sind volle tage
heute was schätzen sie an den grünen
grenzen
die progressive gesellschaftspolitik und
die vielen kolleginnen und kollegen die
ich in den letzten vier jahren kennen
lernt auf die im bundestag und von denen
ich viele auch wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten vier jahren wieder sehen werden
umgekehrte frage frau schäfer was
schätzen sie an der fdp
also ich wollte erst mal persönlich
sagen dass ich eine frau jensen diese
paar arbeit als menschenrechtspolitische
rind für dich auch schon länger verfolge
und ansonsten schätze ich an der fdp
dass sie auch für aufbruch steht und
dafür bei der digitalisierung endlich
voranzukommen das ist auch ein wichtiges
ziel was wir jetzt grüne haben und zu
gesellschaftspolitik hat freuen sich
auch schon einiges gesagt auch da gibt
es überschneidungen zum beispiel was die
abschaffung des § 209 10 a angeht da
werden wir glaube ich sehr viel mehr
schnittmengen haben als in der
steuerpolitik das ist die werbung für
schwangerschafts abbrüche heißt es
jemand nicht aus dem effeff kennt also
es gibt durchaus schnittmengen der
beiden parteien wenn das so harmonisch
kuschelig läuft wie heute mit ihnen
beiden zusammen mache ich mir wenig
sorgen dass wir relativ schnell die
regierung haben werden ich bin gespannt
ich danke ihnen frau an seine frau
schäfer für ihre zeit heute
danke auch
und dann schauen wir uns doch mal an was
die letzten stunden eigentlich so
gebracht haben wir haben dann eine kurze
zusammenfassung für euch
es ist ein wink mit dem blumenstrauß und
olaf scholz will sichergehen dass man
ihn versteht rot gelb grün rote blume
gelbe blume grünes naja es ist das bild
zur botschaft zu scholz wichtigste
botschaft am tag nach der bundestagswahl
sie hat drei parteien gestärkt die
sozialdemokratische partei die grünen
und die fdp und deshalb ist das der
sichtbare auftrag den die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes formuliert
haben diese drei sollen auch die nächste
regierung führen dass mit der union die
zweitplatzierten ebenfalls die regierung
führen wollen prangert scholz nicht im
grundsätzlichen an willy brandt tat es
auch aber im konkreten
cdu und csu haben nicht nur erheblich an
stimmen verloren sondern sie haben
tatsächlich auch die botschafter bürgern
und bürger bekommen sie sollen jetzt
nicht mehr in der regierung sein sondern
in die opposition gehen im
parteivorstand lodern noch einmal
erleichterung hoffnung triumph auf nach
19 jahren verhandelt die spd wieder über
eine kanzlerschaft ein sechsköpfiges
sondierungsteam soll fdp und grünen
jetzt erstmal verlockende angebote
machen und jetzt erst mal keine
bedingungen stellen
deswegen finde ich das von allen seiten
rote linien die über die medien dem
anderen zugespielt werden ein kleines
fenster schließen dass für eine
gemeinsame grundlage wichtig wäre auf
olaf scholz kommen seit vergangener
nacht nicht mehr nur die deutschen
erwartungen zu fragen zur außenpolitik
fragen auf englisch prasseln heute auf
den vielleicht bundeskanzler ein der bis
weihnachten fertig verhandelt haben will
so und den kommentaren lese ich durchaus
zustimmende und ablehnende haltungen zu
der idee dass grüne und fdp miteinander
koalieren könnten ich schaue mal kurz
rein also zum beispiel das darf nur die
ampel sein schreibt first class nehmen
ansonsten werden grün und gelb eine
menge vertrauen und wähler verlieren
wenn es eben zuschauer kommt so deutlich
den kommentar weil ja gerade grünen
weder das habe ich in den letzten
stunden häufig gelesen es nicht gerne
sehen würden wahrscheinlich zumindest
deeley ich so gelesen aber die mir auch
geschrieben haben dass ihre partei die
grünen mit der cdu zusammen koaliert
dann kommt aber ein kritischer kommentar
von paul müller zum beispiel die ampel
kommt ähnlich die fdp wird einen
linkskurs nicht mitmachen ganz im
gegenteil gegensätzlichen meinung hat
jamaika wird es da sonst laschet alles
verlieren wird er wird alles geben was
fdp und grüne wollen das ist auch eine
mögliche situation tatsächlich würde
aber natürlich heißen dass am ende statt
extrem geschwächt ist als kanzler ab
dass eine position ist die die cdu gerne
haben möchte das kann man jetzt mal mit
einem fragezeichen versehen dann habe
ich hier noch ein paar andere kommentare
zum beispiel wie soll eine koalition
fragt michael schnurr jenseits möglicher
inhaltliche übereinstimmungen und
kompromisse unter führung eines kanzler
laschet funktionieren der politisch
schwer angeschlagen ist und dem schon
der rückhalt in der eigenen partei
offensichtlich fehlt das ist eine
anspielung von herrn schnur darauf dass
sich jetzt einige schon in der union zu
wort gemeldet haben die gesagt haben
herr laschet soll doch bitte einen sehen
dass die union die wahl verloren hat und
er soll seinen posten räumen herr
laschet hat da bis jetzt noch nicht
wirklich sich dazu geäußert also noch
handelt er als spitzenkandidat als
kanzlerkandidat und möchte haben wir
gerade gehört von meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann gespräch mit allen parteien
führen ob sich das jetzt zuspitzt in den
nächsten stunden und tagen werden wir
natürlich beobachten und durch auf dem
laufenden halten so und jetzt hörig ist
der politikberater und spd mitglied eric
flügel mir zugeschaltet aber ebenfalls
in berlin im paul-löbe-haus schönen
guten abend
gute nacht der brücke auf größe also wir
wollten sprechen über die frage was
jetzt eigentlich in diesen
koalitionsgesprächen so passiert
beziehungsweise wie die parteien sich
darauf vorbereiten müssen wir haben
gerade die diskussion gehört zwischen
der spd der fdp und der grünen
abgeordneten die sich ja durchaus
vorstellen konnten dass das funktioniert
aber es gibt durchaus auch knackpunkte
wo das nicht so gut läuft
welche fragen müssen sich die parteien
jetzt eigentlich stellen wenn man sich
jetzt auf diese
koalitionsgespräche vorbereitet
na ja im grunde genommen sind wir jetzt
gerade schon mittendrin in koalitions-
vorbereitungen weil natürlich wird ganz
genau beobachtet wie reagiert welche
partei zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auf das
wahlergebnis
allen ist klar dass mehrere parteien
wahrscheinlich drei miteinander
koalieren müssen und deswegen wird ganz
ganz genau hingeschaut da wird
hingeschaut ob die cdu heute mittag ein
ich war in ihren gremien sitzungen da
wurde glaube ich auch mit entsetzen
beobachtet dass alles was dort
besprochen wurde sofort live auf twitter
stand also auch wirklich mit wutanfällen
einzelner absoluter cdu-spitzen die
gesagt haben ich sage jetzt nichts mehr
weil es sowieso sofort wieder in der
bild also das wird wird durchaus dann
mit beobachtet weil man sich die frage
stellen muss mit wem kann man hier
gerade eine verhandlungsbasis herstellen
andererseits muss man schauen mit wem
hat man programmatische gemeinsamkeiten
und muss sich jetzt wo man nach monaten
immer geschaut hat was trennt uns
schauen nach was eint uns das haben sie
jetzt gerade eben der schalter schon
erlebt der blick auf das was eint das
ist das was nach der wahl dann immer
dran ist vor der wahl ist
notwendigerweise das was trend im
mittelpunkt mit kurze anmerkung zum
bildhintergrund ihre flüge ist nicht
fdp-mitglied spricht nicht wie die fdp
das ist jetzt einfach der situation im
bundestag geschuldet der hand einfach so
gewählt ihre krüge ist politikberater
parteiübergreifend aber selber spd
mitglied muss man auch immer mehr
transparenz wegen sagen das heißt könnte
gut sein dass seine partei bald eine
regierung beteiligt ist aber jetzt ist
natürlich die frage die haben da ja wohl
knackpunkte wo man wirklich sie fragen
muss ok wo ist die schmerzgrenze also
haben gerade gehört steuern zum beispiel
da gibt es total unterschiedliche
vorstellungen wie findet man denn jetzt
heraus wie weit man da gehen kann und
wann kommen da quasi die mitglieder und
sagen extra so läuft das nicht
also wir wissen ja dass ganz am ende in
den in den jeweiligen parteien
beschlossen werden muss stimmig diesen
koalitionsvertrag der dann ausgehandelt
ist zwischen partnern welche das sind
wissen wir jetzt noch gar nicht stimmt
dem zu oder stimmen wir dem nicht zu
dafür gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
verfahren wir wissen es noch aus der
letzten regierungsbildung die spd hatte
beispielsweise ein mitgliederentscheid
die cdu hat das in ihren vorständen
entschieden dort muss man am ende durch
kommen deswegen ist die frage die sie
gerade stellen ja durchaus virulent also
wie wie muss man das paket schnüren so
dass am ende alle sagen können wir
können mit gehen oder wir können nicht
mitgehen jetzt gibt es aber in so einem
themenfeld wie den finanzen natürlich
erstmal die großen unterschied sie sind
im wahlkampf ausgearbeitet worden
entlastung alle einkommensgruppen bei
gleichzeitiger akzeptanz von einem staat
oder von einem minus im staatsdefizit
auf seiten der fdp bei grünen und der
spd ein anderes modell starke belastung
bei den höheren einkommen dafür die
entlastung bei den niedrigen einkommen
kostenneutral so dass dann eben kein
defizit beim staat entsteht und das
ganze muss man miteinander verhandeln
und muss man anschauen das besondere ist
dass wir es hier mit fachpolitikerin und
fachpolitikern zu tun haben die das
schon immer so machen bei jeder
haushaltsplan aufstellung thun die das
auch dann setzen die sich hin mit den
groben linien ihrer parteien und schauen
dann genau ins detail rhein wo man
einigkeit erzeugen kann und da sind
viele details zwischen den programmen
beispielsweise von spd und fdp vorhanden
die man jetzt im wahlkampf gar nicht so
besprochen hat die aber durchaus
ähnlichkeiten haben und das ist trotzdem
klar dass im finanzbereich das programm
von cdu und fdp sich näher ist und das
programm von spd und grünen sich jeweils
näher ist und dass das tatsächlich die
beiden lager trend aber die koalition
muss lagerübergreifend gebildet werden
heute man denn dann so als partei immer
mal wieder in die basis rein also dass
man jetzt zum beispiel auch mal sofort
sondiert als grüne partei habe das
überhaupt gehen mit einer cdu wenn jetzt
die spd wenn das nicht funktioniert oder
wie kann ich mir das vorstellen so ein
prozess oder kriegt man da als
parteimitglied als parteivorstand
unzählig viele nachrichten und
direktnachrichten und sms wo er sich
dann so ein bild ergibt dass man sagt
das lassen wir lieber
also es hat schon ganz viel davon
stattgefunden gestern abend hatten ja
alle die kandidiert haben irgendeine
form von wahlparty in ihren eigenen
wahlkreisen sie waren alle noch zu hause
mit ihrer parteibasis haben gefeiert mit
den ehrenamtlichen die sie unterstützt
haben und was war das thema des
gestrigen abends schon wer könnte mit
wem wie könnte das aussehen und es wird
natürlich auch auf diesen auf diesen
partys oder auf diesen
gesprächssituationen besprochen die
abgeordneten bleiben auch während so
eine sondierungsphase nicht komplett
hier in berlin sondern sie sind
natürlich einem engen kontakt mit den
leuten zu hause und kriegen damit dabei
auch schon stimmungen mit aber allen ist
natürlich auch klar dass man sich in
einem strategischen gesamt setting
befindet also mal ganz simpel
irgendeine kombination wird loslegen zu
sondieren das wird nach aller
wahrscheinlichkeit eine
dreierkombination seien entweder wird
die ampel zuerst sondiert oder es wird
jamaika zuerst sondiert sollte jamaica
platzen an einem partner und dann die
ampel oder umgekehrt und dann die ampel
sollte sortiert werden und die
aufplatzen dann bleibt nur noch eine
große koalition übrig die will nun
wirklich niemand aber sie kämen
natürlich dann als letzte option ins
spiel wenn alles andere abgeräumt ist
weil aber grüne und fdp eindeutig in die
regierung streben und eindeutig auch in
dieser legislatur nicht noch eine
weitere große koalition zu lassen wollen
haben wir die absolute klarheit dass wir
in mit einer hohen disziplin und mit
einem hohen und lösungs willen in diesen
verhandlungen unterwegs sind spannender
ist es bei den beiden volksparteien bei
der spd die hat die hat gestern wahlsieg
hingelegt sie haben schon gesagt ich bin
selber mitglied in der spd ist gerade
sind alle glücklich man will den kanzler
stellen man isst man ist in einer großen
einigkeit das kommt auch durch das
wahlergebnis dass man so gute stimmung
hat in der cdu hängt der haussegen
schief man hat acht prozentpunkte
verloren das ist eine krachende
niederlage historische niederlage und da
gibt es noch mal andere fliehkräfte also
wir haben heute schon die ersten
rücktrittsforderungen gegenüber herrn
laschet gehört
die frage ist ob die cdu gerade
überhaupt die chance hat die innere
einigkeit herzustellen dass sie als
erstes in die sondierung geht oder ob es
nicht am ende wahrscheinlicher ist dass
eine ampel zuerst startet weil die union
gar nicht sortiert ist aber die spd kann
ja auch relativ entspannt sein weil sie
hat sowohl mit der fdp als auch mit den
grünen irgendwelche schnittmengen da
kann man sich ist das meine analyse war
schon irgendwie einigen aber da muss man
doch als spd doch jetzt ein bisschen ja
darauf lauern und vielleicht auch
irgendwie versuchen hinten rum was zu
deichseln druck auszuüben dass sich
diese beiden parteien diese kleineren
parteien die sich ja teilweise wirklich
so quer liegen dass die sich einige
schafft man das
also ganz grundsätzlich würde ich nicht
davon ausgehen dass die leiste einigungs
fähigkeit der ist dass die spd sofort
funktionieren würde mit den grünen oder
sofort funktionieren würde mit der fdp
und das rechne ich mit beiden zusammen
woran liegt das die spd übrigens genauso
wie die cdu hat jetzt eben schon eine
längere regierungsgeschichte das heißt
man hat ganz viele traditionen aufgebaut
auch eigene linien politische linien an
die man glaubt von denen man überzeugt
ist und sowohl die grünen als auch die
fdp haben opponiert dagegen und man in
manchen fragen ist sich die opposition
eben auch einig im gegensatz zu den
regierungsparteien und deswegen wird es
auch nicht in diesem dreier gesprächen
so ganz ganz einfach sein dass die spd
eine leichte einigung mit den grünen
eine leichte einigung mit der fdp
herstellen wird nichtsdestotrotz diese
drei partner können zusammen regieren
sie haben es in rheinland-pfalz bewiesen
als ampelkoalition aber es gibt eben
auch das gegenteil diese die partner mit
der cdu dann dabei grüne grüne fdp und
die cdu können zusammen regieren sie
beweisen ist in schleswig holstein also
es sind tatsächlich beide optionen offen
und es entscheidet sich massiv daran in
welchem zustand die beiden großen
volksparteien sind und da sieht es
gerade bei der cdu schlicht und
ergreifend wenn man auf die heutige
nachrichtenlage schaut eher desaströs
aus und nicht so aus als wäre da gerade
eine regierungsfähigkeit vorhanden das
interessante finde ich jetzt das im
wahlkampf irgendwie selten über diesen
möglichen koalitionsoptionen
gesprochen haben so eine dreier
koalition hätte man sich endlich auch
denken können dass sie kommen wird war
aber nie so richtig thema waren die
parteien das schlecht beraten
das waren sie nicht das liegt an das
liegt eigentlich am grundlegenden
strategischen setting mit dem jede
partei aufgestellt war also für die spd
war in diesem wahlkampf die wichtigste
frage die sie in den mittelpunkt rücken
musste scholz oder laschet die
kanzlerfrage die musste sie hochziehen
sollte das haben sie auf großflächen
überall gesehen da stand kanzler
riesengroß drauf und olaf scholz die cdu
wusste dass armin laschet ein extrem
unbeliebter spitzenkandidat ist also
wirklich mit desaströsen
beliebtheitswerten in der bevölkerung
die wollten den nicht als kanzler
deswegen musste die cdu strategisch das
thema wechseln und musste über koalition
reden aber nicht über eine eigene
sondern über die eine von der sie wusste
dass sie die wählerinnen und wähler der
cdu nicht mögen rot rot grün deswegen
haben wir im gesamten wahlkampf von der
cdu dauerhaft attacken auf rot-rot-grün
gehört und diese regierungsoption liegt
ja gar nicht auf dem tisch aber es war
strategisch als als
richtungsentscheidung für die cdu eine
richtige entscheidung darüber den
versuch zu unternehmen aufzuholen in
diesem in diesem lauten getöse der
kanzlerfrage scholz versus laschet im
interesse der spd und der rot-rot-grün
frage im interesse der cdu ist schlicht
und ergreifend die frage wie genau diese
dreierbündnisse funktionieren können
nicht besprochen worden weil kein platz
auf der agenda dafür war nicht mal alle
zusammen entscheidung was strategisch
richtig so zu tun das war zu laut sie
können doch nicht alles auf einmal
besprechen gut dann sind wir gespannt
wie sich die drei parteien ob die sich
einigen welche drei kombinationen sich
einigen ich danke ihnen jetzt der flüge
für diese einschätzungen aus sicht eines
politikberater der jetzt gerade noch ein
bisschen kamera tanzen ybbs ich weiß
nicht wieso aber sie sind
gut aber damit können wir das gespräch
auch beenden vielen dank und wir werden
die nächsten tage und stunden gespannt
darauf gucken wie sich die parteien
verhalten für hier sei aber erst mal
schönen abend noch
und vielen dank auch an sie hier im
stream an die kommentatorin und wir
haben nicht so viel mit aufnehmen können
ich habe festgestellt es gab relativ
wenig fragen er ja statements und
gegenseitige
teilweise beleidigungen wir sind wie
immer bemüht das im griff zu halten weil
wir den kommentar kanal gerne aufhalten
möchten aber vielleicht beim nächsten
mal ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten in
diesem sinne aber wünsche ich erst mal
einen schönen abend und bis zum nächsten
mal noch gut
[Applaus]